[Música]
algunos de ustedes ha tocado alguna vez
un piano
se han dado cuenta que el piano tiene
teclas negras
y tiene teclas blancas
así es la vida la vida es como las
teclas de un piano con teclas blancas y
teclas negras
las teclas blancas representan las
virtudes los aprendizajes las metas las
satisfacciones las alegrías y los deseos
cumplidos
y las teclas negras representan el miedo
la falta de conocimiento la adversidad
la tristeza las frustraciones y el
cansancio
inicie a trabajar en la industria muy
joven fui muy franco con mi madre le
dije ya no quiero estudiar quiero
trabajar quiero crecer quiero ser
alguien
hice diversos trabajos fui ayudante de
albañil
fui instrumentista fui pintor hice
muchas cosas pero una de las cosas más
importantes que me tocaron aprender fue
hacer bombero
de pronto me vi en un departamento donde
había muchas cosas había peligro habría
riesgo
me tomé a la tarea de ir a un curso de
40 horas de operaciones y maniobras
contra incendios
y en el año 1994 inicié en este
departamento trabajar
poco tiempo después estuve en un lugar
en una planta esperando indicaciones
para realizar un trabajo me encontraba
yo con mi equipo de protección personal
viendo hacia donde estaban realizando
unas maniobras y en ese momento una
explosión
lo primero que hice fue correr
para salvar mi vida tuve miedo
pero segundos después dije a dónde vas y
tú eres el bombero
entonces regrese
tomé mi equipo
con todo el miedo del mundo lo quise
conectar no pude me entró la frustración
segundos después sentí una mano en el
hombro volteo que no se escuchaba nada
por el ruido por la vibración no puede
comunicarnos más que a gritos entonces
él me dijo con señas hay una persona ahí
entre los dos entramos
su cara aplastada sin dientes sin camisa
sin un zapato el pantalón desgarrado su
piel cocida entre los dos lo cargamos lo
llevamos a un lugar en ese lugar llegó
una camioneta y se lo llevaron al
servicio médico yo me quedé impactado
esta si de por si soy blanco parecía
lagartija
estaba muy asustado muy impactado
regresamos a nuestro lugar central ahí
nos congregamos y comenzamos a platicar
acerca del suceso minutos después
recibo una llamada telefónica de mi
madre
que trabajaba en el hospital a donde
llegó esta persona
esta persona no pudo ser reconocida por
su madre por la forma en que estaba
desfigurada
y me entero de que era un amigo
el dolor invadió mi corazón la tristeza
la frustración de no poder haber hecho
nada
eso lo tome como herramientas como
fuerza para comenzar a aprender me
comencé a inscribir en cursos fui a
muchos cursos de capacitación fui a
competencias actualmente por ese
esfuerzo y por esa motivación que me dio
el miedo soy facilitador de mi empresa
soy instructor y me encargo de capacitar
a todo el personal que trabaja para
nosotros en cuestiones de seguridad para
que no haya ese tipo de accidentes en mi
centro de trabajo
uno de los sucesos blancos de mi vida
que me marcan y me cambian totalmente
cuando era muy joven no hace mucho
yo me paraba frente a los escenarios y
veía a los cantantes los escuchaba y yo
decía yo quiero estar ahí yo quiero ser
como ellos yo quiero cantar se me dio la
oportunidad de comenzar a hacer teatro
en una asociación donde éramos puros
jóvenes hacíamos teatro hacíamos obras
hacemos rifas hacíamos comparsas y un
día se nos ocurrió hacer unas
fonomímicas imitar a artistas llenamos
un salón como este llegó mucha gente y
todos comenzamos a imitar artistas a mí
me tocó imitar al señor emmanuel
ese día una persona que estaba en el
lugar me observó
le gustó lo que hice me mandó una
tarjeta
cuando vi la tarjeta y dije organización
musical voy a ir
fui fui con otras tres personas
de los cuales el único que quedó fui yo
a partir de ahí comencé a aprender
comencé a ensayar
comencé a prepararme y un 15 de
septiembre de 1989 me subí por primera
vez a un escenario a cantar cante una
canción mexicana que se llama paloma
negra la conocen esa canción fue mi
primer canción fue la primera vez que
cante escenario
poco tiempo después fui invitado a un
lugar a cantar representando a un grupo
de jóvenes rotarios en ese grupo de
jóvenes me invitaron como la estrella
del momento yo me presenté me puse a
cantar como en ese tiempo no existía las
pistas no teníamos tanto acceso a estas
pistas pues yo me puse a cantar a
capella una canción y comencé a cantar y
la gente me empezó a tirar al suelo
empezaron a caer las monedas sentí muy
feo sentí frío
sentí pena pero no dejé de cantar seguí
cantando
seguí cantando y seguí cantando al final
recibió un aplauso ese aplauso me dijo
tienes que seguir tienes que continuar
con este camino poco tiempo después al
cabo de los años iniciamos otro proyecto
después de haber trabajado durante tres
años con mi primer proyecto el siguiente
proyecto fue ya como cantante principal
acompañado de otra cantante los dos
teníamos toda la responsabilidad de
hacer que la gente estuviera feliz que
la gente bailará que la gente se
divirtiera un poco tiempo después por
las cosas de la vida por los cambios
formamos otra organización musical
en donde éramos hermanos y amigos pero
yo todavía tenía ese deseo y las ganas
de hacer mi propio proyecto
en el año 2000 inició con un proyecto
mío en el cual me enfrentó con la
responsabilidad de manejar a todos de
cuidar todos los detalles de absorber
todo el peso y toda la responsabilidad
pero aún así me llenaba de satisfacción
cuando las personas que acudían a
nosotros quedaban satisfechas eso para
mí era muy valioso
poco tiempo después empecé a ver que la
televisión proyectaba programas los
cuales los cantantes se presentaban las
sillas se volteaban y eso me llenaba de
ilusión y de emoción pero decía pero me
si tú ya estás muy viejo para eso
entonces dije un día yo tengo que ir yo
tengo que pisar ese escenario me decidí
llegué a la ciudad de mexico
me inscribí me preparé
puse todo mi empeño
fui elegido me dijeron te hablamos en 20
días recibí la llamada fui a la ciudad
de mexico en la ciudad de méxico hicimos
otra prueba pasamos a esa prueba
posteriormente el día 14 de octubre del
2018 fue la primera vez que salí en la
televisión en ese famoso reality show
para mí fue como
la culminación para mí fue como una
graduación para mí fue como llegar a la
cúspide de un trabajo que vengo
realizando de hace 30 años
la vida para mí es como las teclas de un
piano con las blancas y teclas negras
pero ambas sirven para hacer una música
muy bonita
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]